hi I'm Nick Gillespie for reason TV
today is September 12th and it's a day
the big taxpayer march on Washington
where people from all over the country
are descending on the nation's capital
to protest unlimited government and
runaway government spending the march on
Washington is the culmination of the Tea
Party movement that's been sweeping the
country for the past several months the
tea party people have been portrayed in
many media outlets as nut jobs and
out-of-control radicals we're interested
in finding out whether or not that's
true are they actually strange Rangers
or are they normal Americans so please
join me and my colleagues of Reason as
we fan out through the crowd and we see
who actually showed up and what they're
thinking about contemporary American
politics
the first thing that struck as as
interesting was the sheer size of the
crab we weren't sure if we were going to
run into about 50 people we knew from a
recent happy hour or an actual
nationwide movement people are pissed
there's so many reasons why everybody's
upset here boo Charlie Rangel boot
Charlie Rangel he's a tax cheat he's a
flyer of fraud he's supposed to be a
leader he's not a leader at all stimulus
money hasn't even been spent and we're
starting to get back on track and they
won't do anything but hold on to that
money so we want to know what I would
rather have the first 50 people in the
phone book run our country rather than
what's up there right now because I'm
just opposing tyranny what sits there
any well I've been married for 28 years
i think im gonna quite an expert on
cherry spending the spending the
spending this famine it's gotta stop the
government is out of control its
spending money it doesn't have and it's
getting involved in things that they
have no experience accomplished are
talking about less taxes less government
healthcare spending a lot of money
that's unnecessarily spin all the
bailouts and all that crap spending in
our country is out of control these
people are here they're tired of the
government growing on taking their
choices away taking their money these
people here to take back their control
we think he's basically trying to take
away our way of life and everyone else
here does too I think what makes this
one different is that it seems to be
focused specifically on a protest of
that big government it's not a
right-to-life protest it's not a pro war
protest and i'm trying i don't often
think that there's been one like this i
think the level of concern is as high as
I've ever seen it we asked people where
they were from how much their tickets
cost to get here and what they were
hoping to get out of this
challenges the trip up here costs and
you have ground ball figure ah about
thousand dollars my tickets for about
three hundred fifty dollars and and then
you're staying in the hotel what's the
whole trip to the cost you probably
about 500 apiece I mean I rated people
last night from Oklahoma Texas New
Mexico well we're from Indianapolis we
love our country and we want to do what
we can to keep it from being destroyed
by Obama and his arse I'm here because I
believe we're witnessing a great
American awakening that's going to
restore fiscal responsibility and
limited government I want smart
hardworking American people to be given
the opportunity to earn that's what this
country is all about and to keep
whatever as best they can absolutely
there were at least five buses from
Indiana that came here and I've talked
to a number of the folks they've never
been involved to see the Republicans or
Democrats there's some more self
professed libertarians but this isn't a
party thing are you more upset at the
Republicans with tarp and the bailouts
it started with Republicans I I don't
know where they got the idea that you
can spend yourself into prosperity it
started on the george bush and is
continuing its beginning to escalate
under this current president we were
expecting change and i don't see the
change that we were expecting are you a
Republican or Democrat an independent oh
yeah I currently my Republican card I'm
a former Republican I don't know what
because call my conservative I think
most people wouldn't even classify
themselves as Republicans anyway I mean
there's so sick of the whole ya tu parte
más that they just say I don't want to
be part of either side anymore
Republicans doubled the national debt
when we had a president in the White
House this president has passed a budget
that will triple the national debt hi
you know if I could vote for Thomas
Jefferson for George Washington I would
is this a turning point not really i
think it's going to represent a
realignment of follow
in America people we met were upset with
the way Republicans spent money the way
that Democrats are spending money and
they want government to stop spending
now and they're very interested in
voting the bums out come 2010 we don't
just drain the swamp let it get rid of
everybody all the important all the
incumbents and start you know it's not
whether you're a Democrat or Republican
it's that you've been there too long
you're with the corruption and we need
to change that and that's by voting them
all out everyone must go everyone's I ok
you don't support and defend the
Constitution you go whether or not the
taxpayer march on Washington actually
starts a second American Revolution or
not this much seems pretty clear it was
a good day for limited government and
getting the message out that the best
way to secure America's future is by
reducing the size and scope and
certainly the spending of government for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you